how about this one for you from
americanpress.com biden halts all new
oil and gas leases from wednesday
february 23rd 2022 reported by the ap
the bind administration is delaying
decisions on all new oil and gas
drilling on federal land and other
energy related actions after a federal
court blocked the way officials were
calculating the real-world cost of
climate change what were you just you're
saying
green green guilt and greed
it's a it's a hijacked idea you know and
nobody i don't think at this point
denies the fact that humans have an
influence on the climate around them
right but this idea that we that
everything we do has to be like
renewable and this and that it's a it's
a ruse
to undermine all of these things that
make us fiercely independent this
country can depend on itself we we have
everything that we're one we're a unique
country right we have everything that we
need within our borders to be completely
self-reliant and somehow we are not
we are facing down full-scale ground war
in europe like there is legitimately a
ground war
in europe right now the most significant
halting oil since world war iii and
biden's like
oil and gas we don't need it that should
be something he rubber stamps at this
point yeah until further notice yeah we
have we have a conflict on the horizon
ramp up the machines at home and get
ready
to at least at the very least flex your
muscles
if biden's going to look i'm going to
look at joe biden flexing his muscles
and laughing at this point
excuse me
i got to say spider might be looking in
the mirror
i got to say something that's probably
controversial oh yeah um you know and
it's going to make a lot of people angry
no but donald trump was a better
president than what joe biden but there
are no tweets that's right
yeah i thought about it i thought about
it and i was thinking um
maybe the mean tweets were worth it
maybe it was yeah yeah yeah yeah
energy independence there there are a
lot of things that i disagree with
donald trump on but he is unequivocally
a better and stronger and i think
stronger is is really
in terms of this topic an important
characteristic yeah he is a stronger
president he projects strength in a way
that joe biden i don't think ever could
but nor kamal harris or nor really
anybody on that roster on that side but
i i gotta get a little real with it it's
not hard to be better than joe biden
right now no no no we're not setting the
bar right right
i thought trump was great about not
falling for this kind of global agenda
of corporatization like he got us out of
the trans-pacific partnership within
like two weeks of coming into office he
saw the danger of allowing our citizens
to be sued by corporations because they
didn't want to discriminate they didn't
want to buy malaysian oil like
we're sovereign citizens we don't have
to bow to a corporation that was early
on world economic forum stuff um and
i think that what's happening is that
there are corporate powers that are
putting countries against each other so
that they fight and then they can fall
apart and be like hey see national
governments don't work anymore let us
come in and say i told you guys this
before the show let us come in and save
you with our corporate benevolence yeah
i just wanted
i want to follow this story from the ap
biden halts oil gas leases amid legal
fight on climate costs
russia just invaded and this is february
22nd when they were screaming russia was
going to invade kiev we're talking about
climate cost and he was like well you
know that that little swedish girl
yelled at me so i think cut off the
power oh my god i just i'm flabbergasted
and again for this man even with this
stuff
what what beyond the headline because it
sounds it sounds nice to your you know
to your bleeding heart you know social
justice warrior what does climate cost
actually mean we don't know in in
in that discussion
i think the assumption is that carbon
too much carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere is going to cause a
greenhouse effect which is going to
cause superheating but so we should be
worried that's the worry we should be
worried about the shorelines
disappearing more than we should about a
possible european invasion from russia
like that no that's the calculus
potential invasions are preeminent in in
the forefront i think but
you should not be focusing on
how bad things could get but how to fix
the problem is the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere you gotta i just gotta step
in and say
we've got the potential for
total nuclear annihilation in the
immediate
or but we're looking at that clock
environmental danger a nuclear bomb
going off the atmosphere
exactly it's like it's 10 million years
of this stuff that those two words are
are essentially meaningless climate cost
it's
i'm i'm meaningless
you know the american military is like
the biggest polluter in the world the
amount of crap it dumps into the oceans
with its navy is and its army is like it
as a court if it was a corporation it
would be the largest polluter on earth
i'm sure it probably is and and we're
we're not even high we're not even up
there on the list of of
the people that we're talking about in
this discussion russia china all these
are our polluters of the world these are
people who don't buy this climate crop
you know cost nonsense and and granted
china does a lot of things wrong there's
there's no uh acceptance of the way that
they do things coming from me but
we are worrying about climate cost when
these people are worrying about taking
over entire countries this is it's like
what ben shapiro was saying we're like
we're going to sanction you and then you
can't use the bank and putin's like i
want to rebuild the empire and i'll kill
anyone to get my way exactly we're not
even having the same
you can't buy that
make sure there's a bow on it before you
do it and he's like smashes the wall out
of the way and it's like come on i saw
this build a wall i saw this i saw this
story the other day
and i'm like
my immediate thought process was shut
down the show
shut down all the work we're doing tim
cass is over i'm gonna go but i'm gonna
go buy a coconut sit back put the
sunglasses on put my feet up and be like
it was fun while it lasted it's time
it's time to milk as much time as we got
left because baby we are we are going
downhill from here this this is i mean
this is absurd our priorities are and
again it's not to say that these things
are not important because i'm not i'm
not one to just you know just spit into
the wind because that's what you're
doing when you're ignoring
uh the effects that you do have on the
climate however we need to have some
prioritization of of what is important
and what is not important and and where
we've got it
seemingly completely upside down people
are going to vote for the democrats just
i'm just in november there's going to be
a midterm and it's gonna be close
the democrats could even win
i just i just not andy kim if if you if
you show this article to someone and
you're like russia invaded ukraine biden
decides to stop producing oil and gas
i'm just how are you the party of
vladimir putin is an ex existential
threat and trump was colluding with them
and also and also let's shut down our
energy production it's like the people
who are like we don't like the
government has all the guns let's ban
all the guns yeah except for the
government right except for the yeah
exactly well that's i'm just i'm so
right it's kind of par for the course at
this point you know coming coming from
that side
you know it's it's the it's the
the movement of doublethink and mental
gymnastics because somehow to these
people when they go to the ballot box it
makes sense to them i'm gonna buy a
machete and a bunch of coconuts and i'm
gonna sit downstairs and i'm just gonna
machete open those coconuts and drop a
straw in there and be like i'm i'm i'm
done well before you do that i have to
say i will i will say that i had not
seen the term climate cost before and
that is really interesting to me because
it is super vague it strikes me a little
bit yeah how's that calculated it
strikes me as anti-racism this is one of
the nebulous goals that black lives
matter is fighting for what is climate
cost well we know if we achieve this
goal what is the goal i don't think is
there an equation the opportunity cost
of loss of like the climate getting
hotter calculating this yeah exactly and
they're linear calculations they're not
accounting for change in the the product
the progression so if you develop a new
technology that can recover the carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and turn it
into graphene it dramatically changes
the direction of our of our models and i
think it's been it's been clearly shown
at least to my understanding that
of all the things that we can factor in
to to climate cost and climate change
we're we're we're only
you know accounting for a quarter of of
the things that actually come into play
so
this equation that we're that we're
basing
domestic policy on is
not a very good one yeah an asteroid
could completely annihilate the surface
yeah that's climate change yeah it's
just it's you know it again you you have
to prioritize and this is this is this
is pure
uh this is this is par for the course of
what we're seeing you know what what do
we prioritize at home we're prioritizing
you know all of these ludicrous agendas
meanwhile our country is legitimately
falling apart from the inside
i can't imagine that uh the us can
survive something as insane as this i
mean we're talking about our energy
infrastructure and we're not just
talking about that we're talking about
that plus
war
when you're a country
that cannot put aside
you know long-term climate goals
to deal with
present emergencies existential crises
you're doomed
i mean it's it's like
the united states is looking at russia
and they're like we would rather die
than pollute the the air that's
essential
that's essentially what that headline
reads yeah
it is so it is so strange to me that
people who can't ever think past stage
one are now thinking so far into the
future that they can't look at an actual
possible nuclear war and be like oh
maybe we should put this on the back
burner for maybe a month or two while we
figure in a while yeah just like an
actual just turn them on until we get
this situation under control and then we
can resume that
less important discussion i can't
believe that yo
i don't know man what's going to happen
aliens are going to invade yes please
force save us oh yeah i think save us
the solution is meditation is is prayer
and meditation i don't know i heard
thoughts for ukraine
prayers for ukraine yeah and then and
then silent mind you do the prayer of
healthy or whatever you want to pray and
then
absence of thought for as long as you
want alex jones told me that if if you
uh you do dmt you can speak to the
machine elves who will grant you the
secrets to the universe so let's do it
maybe they're going to help save all of
us
because
i'm trying to find a conventional way to
fix and it just keeps getting worse and
worse and worse and worse and infected
and more black mold and like right right
it's got to be some psychoactive
solution no there's there's rumors
already
that they've already been shuffling off
shuttling out
prominent high-profile political figures
into bunkers now i don't know if that's
true or not but in ukraine no no in the
united states okay yeah i i don't know
ran away from truckers so uh maybe yeah
there's they're surprised perhaps but
there's there's rumors going around that
some flights have left and they're going
to areas with underground bunkers i
don't know if it's true maybe it's not i
hope it's true if we're if we're
literally on the verge of potential
chaos we need our well our political
fleet is happening do we
i know i hate we're not allowed but yeah
we do no no no no no no no he is an
middle of the field right at this point
i was wondering is kamala harris a more
competent leader could you imagine joe
biden on horseback like meeting the
charge
no can't that'd be cool he would be able
to get up i'd be wild
to the horse they used to do that i got
a weekend at bernie sanders thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you